olá muito cara e ele também
meu nome é rita peroni insolo cantora na
cadeia comercial a ao contrário do que
possam pensar não vim aqui falar de uma
coisa incrível extraordinária possa ter
feito na rádio
ao que parece a minha vida é a história
da minha vida é muito mais interessante
que a minha história profissional e vai
tomar isso como uma coisa boa
portanto eu estou aqui para vos falar do
meu trabalho como voluntária em campos
de refugiados
assim de repente podem partir das coisas
hoje completamente diferente uma coisa
da outra portanto fazer voluntariado e
fazer rádio mas eu sei que é um
denominador comum entre estes dois
universos que é precisamente o que o
filho estava a dizer quanto mais faz mas
quer fazer
acredito que muitos de vocês já tenham
ouvido falar do clássico bichinho der
sar viu né
há quem diga que é uma espécie de vírus
que toma conta e não do nosso corpo mas
da nossa alma é um vírus que um bicho
gera afetividade intimidade e
cumplicidade
neste mundo de ajudar o próximo e eu
também acredito que haja um bichinho o
bichinho e creche e se alimenta a dívida
que nós experimentamos todos a sensação
em comensurável de ajudar a largar em
criar laços em de afetos com
desconhecidos ver a intimidade famílias
que fogem da guerra que fogem da
instituição levam literalmente a vida em
sacos plásticos que não perdem a fé em
mim muito pessoalmente a magia de dar
nem sabe o que é uma coisa que se fala
muito em tudo semelhantes é um sorriso
malandro eco de uma criança
uma criança que não dura nem como marias
e vias podem ser 18 vias que não dorme
como deve ser na sua cama mas repente
sendo 1 24 que eu acho que vocês todos
conhecem ou vida que deus quiser
é numa estação de comboios em viena como
festa aconteceu na minha primeira viagem
a um campo de refugiados e vai todo
contente estou contente a correr mostrar
aos amigos e aos pais o presente que
quer ganhar
uma dinâmica é vida é bela não sei se
vocês já viram o filme e portanto fazer
pausa nesta cultura do conforto em que
em que vivemos muitos nós e pôr as mãos
na massa eu acho que é o melhor da vida
acredito cada vez mais nisso
só que eu acho que é uma coisa que eles
não sabem é como e com quem nunca quis
ter um filho e de repente engravida a
primeira coisa que irá assim que o bebê
mexer é se eu soubesse que ia ser assim
tinha tido mais cedo
agora pense nisso talvez eu não tenha
dito mas que para eu fui aos 25 anos e
acho que hoje em dia já ninguém
já ninguém tem filhos com a ser a
estrela dizer que se isso salvar é 100
otan que servem de cada vez que ajudam
alguém e eu acho mesmo que no mundo
abria mais mas é mais sujo que ajudam em
verde beneficiários mais voluntários do
prof se áreas
posto isto a primeira vez que o
convidaram para fazer esta troca vou ter
que ser muito sincera é a primeira coisa
que eu pensei foi nem pensar não vou não
vou é emprestar uma logo os monstros
todos que o time estava a falar a cada
os monstros do pânico
portanto nem pensar não vou nem paga um
milhão de euros o que não paga nada que
é o caso não vou não vou é uma coisa é
estar dentro da rádio sim a falar para
um milhão em maio ouvindo todos os
mesmos da minha coxinha ninguém vê
estou feliz que minha outra
completamente diferente estar aqui nesse
fla neste palco em frente a uma platéia
muito esclarecida e portanto via assim
esse meio do palco e diz logo vi uma
questão que nem estava aqui o espírito
que era que eu vou ensinar às pessoas
para eu sou uma mulher de 32 anos um
pessoa perfeitamente normal muito
família tenho meu trabalho e portanto as
plantas não sou o guru esta temática dos
refugiados em gaza não sou nem questão
de imigrações nem atrações
internacionais da minha cabeça o que eu
dizia o fernando que foi convidado a
convidou marcos o antónio terra
o confiança lá mas foi felizmente tive
alguns meses para pensar sobre isso e
acho que pensei bem e dei comigo as
tantas porque não há por que não ir lá
frio
estive lá fui eu que corri os tais três
mil e quinhentos quilômetros com uma das
minhas melhores amigas numa não manchará
convicta que podia fazer alguma coisa
queria fazer a diferença ainda é muito
pequenina na vida daquelas pessoas que
eu conversei com elas phil que saberá
sair que explicar e que podia acontecer
daqui pra frente que vai duas mochilas
que eram os meus filhos saírem os
brinquedos para distribuir por aquelas
crianças fio que se sente o cheiro o
medo e sim teve também nos olhos
daquelas pessoas
angústia o desespero a ansiedade é
soldado que é uma coisa que está muito
presente mas também a esperança de
chegar a um porto seguro
fui exigente sai menos no que é o corpo
desde o haiti antes de ir
vemos ouvimos e lewis não podemos
ignorar as palavras sábias final bryan
fizeram tanto sentido para mim naquela
altura eu acho que como muitos de vocês
assim o trabalho de dezenas de artigos
em revistas e jornais ouvir as notícias
na rádio via imagens de centenas e até
milhares de pessoas que movem que
morreram afogadas no mediterrâneo é
todos os dias que é um momento em que
uma criança de 3 anos uma criança síria
aparece morta em uma praia inerte cabeça
fundada na praia inicia o sivicc não ia
mudar de canal
eu ia pôr mais alto e foi quando tudo
sai no grupo famílias como as nossas
o facebook é tão amiga a convidou para
ser o piloto a ir com ela até o pato
aprovados e é um descampado que cantava
na altura mais de três mil e 500
refugiados na croácia por dia
é importante o lá fomos nós
convicta já está curiangos fazer alguma
coisa que poderíamos fazer a diferença e
que queremos ajudar aquelas pessoas
tanto que tivemos em um platô watts
quase dois dias
estávamos convictos que podemos fazer em
alguma coisa
- no fundo fazer com que os governos
alguns dos governos tinham propostas que
não acontecia e vamos trazer a família
está refugiado sírio para portugal mas
nem tudo correu mal e tudo mesmo tudo
correu mal desde os modos legais que nos
enviam de transportar refugiados ao
facto de entrega integraram cima uma
caravana solidária que não conhecemos
ninguém e as duas pela copa fora
portanto tudo podia acontecer tem que
tirar férias do trabalho é que temos que
gastar dinheiro do nosso bolso os filhos
saudáveis enfim esteja provocar mal e
prometeu fazer isso porque foste eu vou
respondê los como a outra pergunta se eu
gostava de pensar em um trem
já uma vez estiveram verdadeiramente nos
a ser elemento apaixonados por alguém
tem de tudo pra correr mal e mesmo assim
atiraram na cabeça
eis meu amor eu falar mais alto é uma
coisa que não se explica nos vêm das
entranhas que é excecional que mexe com
todos os nossos sentidos e que não há
outra opção vai aceitar nada e fui a um
teste do que tudo que gosto muito do
professor e físico né cury quando vim da
minha segunda viagem da cidade a crise
assim a capacidade de nos encontrarmos
de nos impressionarmos temos governos o
que se passa à nossa volta é o conjunto
da humanidade
se o sofrimento dos outros não nos toca
é porque já não sabemos que cada homem é
um homem tão homem como nós essa é
igualdade fundamental e essa capacidade
nos 5 usarmos nos impressionarmos com
o que está à nossa volta nos deu tanto
mas tanto comigo
a determinada altura dei por mim vale
lágrimas um contentor minúsculos e da
roupa até acima roupa usada é que os
chamavam carinhosamente de boutique em
lágrimas vezes já depois de uma daquelas
situações que nos deixa completamente
fora de tempo passava o que aconteceu eu
fui buscar uma menina 34 anos e vai
atender da unicef alemães então estavam
separados do resto do grupo de
refugiados
eu estava assistindo e alcançado tanto
que ela não tinha nada prestigia com
suporte a todos rotos ea gente chega um
comboio a um campo de refugiados dentro
do campo
então você ter uma ideia quando chegam
com dói é um campo de refugiados
imagina e uma gestão que os com não sai
três mil pessoas que acontecem no rio já
no rio de janeiro nesta manhã percebeu
que com boyd investigado e que estava
toda a gente é mobilizar porque vem das
suas e entraram mais depressa no combóio
o único objetivo entrar em serem os
primeiros a entrar no combate a fazerem
mais 100 quilômetros 200 quilômetros em
direção ao norte em direção a manhã em
direcção a que todos acreditam que um
novo i
a mãe percebeu que estava toda a gente
de mobilizar e que ela ficar fora do
grupo e prender o marido eo resto da
família começa ela também numa corridas
histriônica esteira e esperava os gritos
pelo canto surge atos
é impressão ao comboio sem por um
segundo olhar pra trás e sim por um
segundo perceber que o mais importante
da vida dela está fazendo com que era
filha e dizendo que queria fazer fui
correr atrás dela também nesta criança
que tenha já chorava tem três anos e
estava em um quarto para quedas vieram e
correto junto aos gritos e amanhã entra
dentro do comboio quando entra dentro do
comboio para sair e ela vai embora e
vamos deixar a criança nos braços
infelizmente encontrou o sorriso
encontrou essa família e era uma família
como as nossas
a criança é esta
ninguém eles não é esta fotografia foi
tirada
cinco minutos antes deste episódio que
contém somente assim um segundo antes do
tempo está tudo calmo mas amigo
movimento através da fotografia porque
problemas tempo feliz que essa criança
estava sabe onde está hoje toda contente
com a roupa nova e com os ténis nós e eu
acho que vocês também que eu possa
desencantar um sorriso porque mais uma
vez entramos na dinâmica de vela e as
crianças felizmente tem muito isso
conseguem abstrair se do causa em
questão
mas se eu disser são precisas 19 horas
para nos 19 horas para dizer todos os
nomes todos os nomes das crianças que já
morreram nesta guerra que atualmente
existem quase cinco milhões de
refugiados
estes miam miam número o refúgio da
guerra e da instituição e quais 4.000
afogados no mediterrâneo seu nome nas
costas a gente tem acesso não é uma
informação privilegiada tanto tropeçando
dentro somos todos os dias mas sim há
muita gente que já que roriz é tão
triste enfim muda de canal
mas eu decidi fazer alguma coisa o
suspense chamamentos ainda que eu acho
que não há limitação para freira uma boa
vontade uma coisa da qual eu tinha
certeza absoluta e tem ainda e isso leva
é um livro que eu andei lerá os tempos
não é sim uma obra prima da literatura
chamas as coisas que vivi me ensinou da
oprah winfrey e não uma compilação das
minhas crônicas da oprah vista dela para
a capital e na primeira crônica se não
me engano ela conta que em 1998 foi
entrevistado em directo um aclamado
crítica de cinema é para a provisão e
portanto quase no fim da entrevista eu
perguntou ele diga do que tenha certeza
ela fingiu que não tínhamos feito vai no
sentido da pergunta e tentou fim da
minha volta e eu falei que não respondeu
mas teve durante 16 anos à procura de
respostas
e se vocês pensarem que vinha thomas já
pensei sobre isso não é fácil
há poucas coisas na vida das quais nós
temos a certeza absoluta
isso vai produzir o que é que eu não sei
se irá ajudar refugiados fez nenhuma de
sua melhora ou se é preciso ser boa
pessoa pra fazer isto mas que é o dia de
hoje 21 mais sou muito melhor olhar pro
lado meu jardim tenha certeza absoluta
aliás quando da minha primeira viagem à
croácia prendeu um ditado judaico dizia
assim salvo uns prova uma viagem e
salvar a humanidade
acho que não nós do grupo como as nossas
tem essa pretensão
não tínhamos essa missão salvar a
humanidade
mas o objetivo não deixava de ser vale
nós criam sim salvar famílias como as
nossas crianças ajudar a única certeza é
a ser queríamos ajudar as crianças
criamos na televisão
queremos exercer o poder que teve um de
nós nesta sala tem a dizer gêneros e
praticar essas novidades portanto é isso
muita gente também crise que é um tipo
de obesidade já falou que hoje é uma
generosidade egoísta e eu tenho que ser
muito honesto eu concordo é assim o
altruísmo e eu muitas vezes e concentre
e narcísico precisamente pouco explicado
porque é um momento em que eu eo grupo e
muitas pessoas que fazem este trabalho
voluntariado é conseguir aumentar o
nosso amigo latina para quem acredita
nessas coisas e eu acredito nos dissesse
paulo e talento e trabalho que tanto
ajuda também dá uma mãozinha e 50 como
se nós tivéssemos uma espécie de super
poder é que não gosta de ter um
superpoder um poder que podem frear e
que interfere mesmo extinta aquelas
pessoas na vida daquelas pessoas ou
porque damos dinheiro pra combóio ou
porque simplesmente nos damos dinheiro a
portuguesa já os sapatos novos para
fazerem mais mil quilômetros pp e não
com boy acreditamos leite em pó que é
uma coisa que não existe num campo de
refugiados e e portanto no fundo isso há
poucas coisas na vida que nos dão tanto
fazer como como ajudar alguém que nos
dão a sensação de satisfação connosco
próprios e até de sentido da nossa
própria vida e termina dizendo das duas
vezes que estive em campos de refugiados
e esperava voltar este ano ainda não
tinha chegado à casa reagiu e ainda não
tinha entrado com no avião e no carro do
regresso a casa e minha cabeça já só
pensava quando fins de semana é que eu
teria para voltar lá quantos quiserem
que eu ainda tinha há ou não mas ela
confia que eu possa ajudar o fim de
semana para voltar lá lá aonde poucos
querem saber que muitos não querem estar
e minha resposta é muito obrigado